it's been over 35 years since nintendo's
classic platformer super mario bros
side-scrolled into our world
and across those glorious three and a
half decades nintendo have treated us to
an absolute master class
in action platforming from the iconic
level design of super mario bros world
1-1
through the groundbreaking 3d action of
super mario 64
to the ever varied capture mechanics of
super mario odyssey
nintendo's flagship franchise has
constantly been evolving
[Music]
and so today i'm going to chart that
evolution from the series 1985 origins
through to its status as one of the most
iconic and popular franchises in all of
gaming
this is the evolution of mario
[Music]
while super mario's odyssey began back
in 1985
the origins of the italian plumber are
actually rooted earlier
in a certain sailor man back in 1981
nintendo tasked shigeru miyamoto with
creating a game around the popular
american cartoon
miyamoto obliged and designed a game
that saw popeye scaling ladders to
rescue olive oil
from the evil brutus when it transpired
that nintendo didn't actually have the
rights to popeye
miyamoto had to think on the fly to
create new characters for his game
brutus became the iconic titular ape
donkey kong
olive oil became a lady called lady
before being upgraded to pauline and
well popeye became nintendo's famous
mascot
a squat mustachioed man called jumpman
while jumpman seemed like an active
perhaps a little too literal name for
their new mascot
the name sadly didn't stick but the
mechanics certainly did
and it came to define the character the
franchise and hell even the whole genre
jumpman eventually became mario in 1982
when the name started appearing in
promotional materials for donkey kong
arcade cabinets
allegedly a tribute to the landlord of
nintendo of america's first hq in
seattle
and the name was cemented even further
in donkey kong jr which
interestingly is the only instance where
mario is the villain the game he appears
in
fast forward to 1983 and mario became
the start of his own game
mario brothers was an incredibly
simplistic action platformer by
nintendo's future standards
ostensibly playing out like a wave-based
combat game where mario or luigi
were tasked with killing off critters by
hitting the floor beneath them
before kicking them off screen it's safe
to say the mechanic did not catch on
but two years later mario returned for
one of the most defining moments in
gaming history
super mario brothers released for the
nez in 1985
and laid the foundations for everything
that would come to define the franchise
at the time the nez was largely
populated with single screen games
much like mario brothers but super mario
brothers introduced a right scrolling
movement
that matched the player as they moved
through the level it brought a real
sense of adventure and forward
progression
and coined the term side scroller which
would become the benchmark for the genre
for years to come
coupled alongside this new
side-scrolling dynamic was a clearly
defined structure too
the game was mapped out across eight
worlds each made up of four levels
for a total of 32 courses the game has
chewed the darker aesthetics in new york
setting of mario brothers relocating the
franchise to the brighter hues of the
mushroom kingdom and introduced a new
antagonist for our portly plumber
bowser or king cooper
from a gameplay perspective the game was
designed to build upon the satisfaction
that players got from jumping over
obstacles in both donkey kong and mario
brothers
a gameplay mechanic that super mario
brothers would literally run with
the controls were perfectly pitched and
with world 1-1 the player had the ideal
playground with which to experiment in
and then there were the power-ups that
have now become synonymous with the
franchise
firstly there was the dubiously titled
magic mushroom which turned regular
mario into
super mario and granted him the ability
to take an extra hit
then there was the fire flower which
gifted mario the ability to throw
fireballs and lastly there was the
starman ability which sadly has nothing
to do with bowie
and gave mario a brief stint of
invincibility
super mario brothers was a huge hit
selling well over 40 million units
worldwide
and it's not hard to see why with
groundbreaking gameplay an eye-catching
aesthetic and some of the most
iconic music in all of video games
[Music]
super mario bros became an instant
classic and kickstarted a beloved new
franchise
a franchise that would get a sequel
almost immediately but wait
here's where things get a little
confusing
[Music]
okay so super mario brothers the lost
levels was technically speaking
the second installment of the franchise
as it was released for the famicom disc
system in japan in 1986
under the name super mario bros 2.
although do not confuse it with the
other super mario brothers 2 which
released across the world in 1988 and we
will get to that in due time
right back to 1986. the lost levels is
basically more of the original super
mario brothers
only far more challenging
the core gameplay remained much the same
from the previous installment
the difficulty had been ramped up
considerably for an extra challenging
experience
it was a far larger game too spanning 52
courses across
13 worlds but good luck getting through
all those then there were a handful of
new little treats for players too
most notably the introduction of a
poisonous mushroom which was the first
power-up you encountered in the game and
well killed you and if that isn't a
statement i don't know what is
[Music]
okay now for the other super mario
brothers 2 which came out for the nez in
1988
and threw out nearly everything that
players had come to associate with the
franchise
for starters you might think to jump on
the head of the first enemy you
encounter in order to kill them
right well no that's because super mario
brothers 2 is a mario game in disguise
this sequel was actually based on yumi
kojo doki doki panic or
dream factory heart racing panic and
neither of those are easy to say
which was a japan only release it was
adapted to fit into the mario franchise
and well that's why it feels so
different to the rest of the series
you see super mario bros 2 or umi kojo
doki doki panic
was designed as a harvesting action game
which saw you stand atop enemies and
items and root them out from the ground
which feels like the exact opposite of
the classic gameplay that players saw in
super mario brothers
this slightly off-kilter sensibility was
reflected in the game's plot too
which took place in a dream world called
subcon and saw mario sucked into a quest
to defeat a regal frog called war
yet it's weird the game was still a lot
of fun and gave you the opportunity to
play as four different characters with
varying abilities there was mario who
naturally had average abilities all
round
luigi who could pump his little legs to
get a little more airtime
princess toadstool who could float in
the air for a few seconds and then
toad who was just a bit rubbish really
super mario brothers 2 was a huge
success in the states and was eventually
reverse imported back to japan
where it had to be renamed as super
mario usa because japan already had a
super mario brothers 2.
okay i promise you the confusion stops
here
[Music]
1989 super mario land were the franchise
go handheld for the first time
and the transition to the small screen
for the large part was pretty smooth
released as a launch title for
nintendo's fancy new game boy
super mario land put the plumber in the
palm of your hand oh that sounds
weird and successfully adapted a lot of
the classic super mario brothers
gameplay to the smaller screen
it was a far shorter game than previous
iterations featuring just 4 worlds and
12 courses
but it introduced princess daisy into
the franchise for the first time and
gave mario a handful of new power-ups
and abilities
in place of the fire flower was the
super bowl flower which saw mario
throwing super balls that would bounce
around the level
but even better than that with the
vehicles the marine pop and the sky pop
basically a submarine and a plane that
pretty much turned the game into a
shooter
okay so if super mario bros 2 was the
weird second album
super mario bros 3 is the band back to
the absolute peak of its powers
released for the nez in 1990 this fourth
console entry was a huge technical leap
forward for the pluckiness super mario
brothers 3
introduced a whole load of new
characters power-ups and
enemies into the franchise for the first
time most notably the unique end of
world bosses the koopalings
the explosive bob-ombs and the tenacious
boo
all of which would become series
mainstays on the power-ups front mario
bros 3 went
mad introducing raccoon mario tanooki
mario frog mario
shoe mario yeah that last one was a bit
weird but chief among all the new stuff
was a brand new world map that gave a
far greater sense of scope and scale to
the adventure
and allowed you to pick your own route
through each world to the koopaling's
castle at the end of each section
super mario bros 3 was a fantastic
evolution of the franchise and was
enormously popular to boot
selling well over 17 million copies for
the nes and even spawning its own
saturday morning cartoon as well
nasty time is over koopa get those
goombas back in that cage
not only did it have a huge impact on
the super mario franchise
but its non-linear structure had a huge
impact on gaming as a whole
giving gamers a greater sense of choice
to move backwards and forwards through
the levels at their own pace
[Music]
how did nintendo follow up making one of
the greatest nez games of all time
well simple they made super mario world
one of the greatest snez games of all
time
with a more powerful console nintendo
conjured up a whopping
16 bits and just look at those glorious
pixels
super mario world was a far more vivid
and bright adventure which saw the
plummer brothers head on holiday to the
tropical paradise of dinosaur land
meeting a key ally in the process
yeah super mario world introduced us to
yoshi the trusty dino steed of mario for
the first time in the franchise
and well he's pretty much been a
mainstay ever since while super mario
world expanded on the series has now
established formula in relatively minor
ways it was a vibrant platforming
adventure that offered up some of the
franchise's greatest level design to
date
super mario world gave us labyrinthine
haunted houses
joyous free-running levels that allowed
mario to literally soar into the sky
with the new power up the cape feather
and tying it all together was a gorgeous
overworld that was filled to the brim
with secrets for the players to discover
following on from mario's first handheld
foray super mario land 2
6 golden coins released in 1992 and was
a far larger adventure than its
predecessor this handheld sequel
featured 32 levels and had a more
sophisticated art style
based on the recent release of super
mario world for the snares but most
importantly it introduced reprehensible
mario pretender wario into the franchise
cannon for the first time
[Music]
following on from the precedent set in
super mario bros 3 and super mario world
six golden coins offered even more
freedom to players allowing you to
tackle any of the six worlds from the
get-go
on offer you had the macro zone which
saw a tiny mario fend off attacks from
giant ants
the spooky pumpkin zone which had the
atmosphere of a haunted house carnival
ride and the space zone
which saw mario don a space suit and jet
off into the stars for the first time a
site that would become very familiar
within the galaxy games later on in the
franchise
if super mario world was an evolution of
the classic mario formula
super mario 64 was a full-blown
revolution
we all know now that mario 64 basically
reinvented the wheel when it came to 3d
action games but when you look back it
truly was a groundbreaking game in many
ways
not only did it shift the plumber to the
third dimension but the n64's mad
controller gave mario a far
greater suite of platforming moves like
the triple jump and the wall jump
and then there was the roaming camera
that would follow mario around to pick
up the best angle of the action
cutely contextualized within the game's
world as being filmed by lakitu himself
and on the gameplay front super mario 64
basically threw out
everything that you'd come to know and
love about the franchise's now classic
formula
no longer were you walking on tightropes
when you were down to regular mario as
you had a health wheel which you could
regenerate by collecting coins
in fact pretty much all the standard
powers were gone instead of magic
mushrooms and fire flowers mario 64 gave
us the iconic metal mario
and the exhilarating wing mario
then there was the game structure which
had completely been overhauled the
semi-linear overworlds from the 2d mario
games were largely gone in favor of a
grand open world rendition of the
mushroom castle
mario 64 gave us its iconic worlds in
the form of paintings hung on the walls
of the castle
which mario would jump through to enter
each level and scour for power stars
the more stars you collected the further
you could advance through the game
it was a truly refreshing structure
which put the exploration center stage
by giving you the choice of how you
navigated through the game
super mario 64 as we all now know was a
huge success
not only was it the best-selling game on
the n64 shifting over 12 million copies
but it also set the benchmark for how 3d
action games
were to be designed for decades to come
[Music]
here
fans had to wait a massive six years for
the follow-up to super mario 64
when super mario sunshine finally
released in 2002 for the gamecube
while it didn't garner the same levels
of acclaim as its predecessor sunshine
was still a colorful and joyous
expansion of the 3d side of the mario
franchise that took the plumber on
holiday to the gorgeous isle delfino
front and center was the unique power-up
the flood which gave mario the ability
to hose water everywhere
a trick that helped him clean up all the
muck capes around delfino plaza now now
boys don't touch that stuff
and a gameplay mechanic that surely
inspired the nintendo shoot em up
splatoon
flood was a fun if chaotic addition to
the 3d mario experience and could be
upgraded with extra power-ups like the
hover nozzle
mario sunshine expanded on the formula
from mario 64 and saw the eponymous
plumber tracking down
shine sprites from various worlds
attached to the central hub
of delfino plaza while the game wasn't
the success sales-wise that nintendo
were after
it has since become a cult favorite
among mario aficionados
[Music]
if the six year wait for a new 3d mario
felt long
it was 14 years before we got our next
2d mario adventure
fittingly titled new super mario bros
released in 2006 on the nintendo ds new
super mario brothers saw the franchise's
return to its 2d roots and the classic
formula that nintendo had perfected with
super mario world but for all its
familiarity this latest 2d outing
offered a
fair few twists on the classic formula
firstly there was the influence of the
3d titles
which saw some key moves added into the
2d arena
notably the ground pound and the wall
jump which came in really handy when you
had to save yourself from falling down a
hole
then there was the gimmicky new
power-ups including the ability to turn
the central plumber into mega mario for
a quick shot of catharsis or mini mario
to access secret areas
not only was new super mario bros a huge
sales success
selling over 30 million copies to date
but it completely revived the 2d formula
and kickstarted a new side franchise in
the burgeoning mario cannon
[Music]
a year later mario escaped to the one
place that hadn't been corrupted by
capitalism
space yeah super mario galaxy launched
in 2007 for the wii
and saw mario rocket into the stars for
his third 3d game to date
galaxy largely continued the 3d series
structure featuring a central hub
this time in the form of the relaxing
vibes of comet observatory and 120 power
stars defined across the cosmos
aside from introducing us to rosalina
and loomer galaxy evolved the 3d wing of
the mario franchise in a few small but
notable ways
first there was a raft of new power-ups
including b mario
boom area and spring mario but then
there was the gravity-defying physics
system that led to some incredibly
inventive level design
there were spherical planets black holes
and exhilarating flights through the
stars
that made galaxy feel like a refreshing
twist on the 3d formula
as a wii title super mario galaxy made
use of the wii remote sensors
you could attack enemies by shaking the
wii remote or you could collect star
bits by simply pointing the remote at
the screen
and then there was a multiplayer of
sorts for the first time in a 3d mario
although it was largely just your mate
trying to collect star
bits with a second wii remote super
mario galaxy launched a unanimous
acclaim
much of it heaped at its innovative
gameplay level design
and fantastic soundtrack the game would
go on to sell nearly 13 million copies
scoop up countless game of the year
awards and would eventually lead to an
equally acclaimed sequel that i'll get
to very shortly
[Music]
but first nintendo made a return to
their re-established 2d mario series
with new super mario brothers wii which
released in 2009 for the
wii this wee sequel was largely more of
the same that players saw back in 2006's
new super mario brothers but that added
one key element to the 2d franchise
multiplayer for the first time in 2d
mario 4 players could race through
courses as mario
luigi or if you were really unlucky a
blue or a yellow toad
it made for a fun and chaotic experience
where players could team up to and cover
out of reach secrets and simultaneously
ground pound enemies
outside of the multiplayer there were a
handful of new power-ups as well
including ice mario propeller mario and
my personal favorite penguin mario
because well penguins are awesome new
super mario brothers wii was another
massive success for the 2d side of the
franchise selling just a shade over 30
million copies
for a game that was originally an
expansion pack codenamed super mario
galaxy moore
super mario galaxy 2 was exactly that
more of super mario galaxy
which to be clear was no bad thing sure
taken at face value mario galaxy 2
looked like it just
iterated in what had been done in the
original game but looks were deceiving
galaxy 2 perfected its predecessor's
gameplay and introduced ideas that were
left on the original's cutting room
floor
chief among those lost mechanics was the
reintroduction of yoshi which gave you
the ability to gobble up enemies and
items using the wii remote to point
yoshi's extendable tongue around
then there were a smattering of new
power-ups that included a spin drill
item that allowed you to drill down
through the core of a planet a cloud
mario outfit that allowed you to conjure
up cloud platforms out of nowhere
and the rock mario power-up that turned
the plumber into a big hulking boulder
all of which offered unique gameplay
within some incredibly inventive level
design
and then instead of the comet
observatory from the first game we got a
spaceship in the form of a giant mario
head
that acted as the hub world for mario's
adventure filled with its own share of
secrets to discover
while super mario galaxy 2 didn't sell
as well as its predecessor
many believed it to be the better game
mainly due to its bolder ideas
challenging level design and fantastic
bosses and it was the very first mario
title to claim a perfect 10 out of 10
score right here at gamespot
[Music]
the next handheld mario game came in the
form of 2011 super mario 3d land
which launched for nintendo's flashy new
handheld the 3ds
bridging the gap between the 2d and 3d
mario pillars
super mario 3d land offered up a less
challenging adventure that aimed to
appeal to those who had a hard time
playing the 3d games
the game was structured like a more
traditional 2d mario title
with players venturing through a level
to get to the goal poll at the end
but it played with a more freeform
movement that allowed players to make
use of many of mario's abilities from
the 3d games
then there were the tails there were
tails everywhere
and this was all thanks to the return of
the super leaf which turned mario into
tanooki mario
and allowed him to clobber enemies with
his tail and float through the air but
it wasn't only mario had a tail there
were
tail goombas tail boos there was a big
old tail tree hell even the game's logo
had a tail
while it didn't really utilize the 3ds
capabilities all that much
i mean the 3d itself was largely
optional super mario 3d land was a fun
little game
which sold nearly 13 million copies and
led to a vastly more substantial sequel
two years later for the wii u
[Music]
mario had the midas touch in the third
entry into the new super mario brothers
series which saw levels littered with a
way above average amount of gold coins
many of the power-ups introduced for
this game were in service of making
mario a millionaire
there was the gold mario power-up which
gave mario the ability to fling about
gold fireballs and
turn pretty much everything into coins
and then there was the gold block which
gave mario a big old gold brick for a
head and spawned up to 100 coins as you
move through levels
while new super mario bros 2 didn't
garner the same level of acclaim as
other entries into the series it was
still a success for nintendo
selling way over 13 million copies which
was well over
double what the other new super mario
brothers game that released in 2012
sold
[Music]
yeah 2012 saw two new super mario
brothers games as the wii u
saw the release of new super mario bros
u one upping new super mario brothers
wii
the wii u sequel had multiplayer where
five players could play simultaneously
four playing on the tv with the fifth
using the wii u's gamepad to interact
with the game's environment by
controlling certain mechanisms and
stopping enemies in their tracks
while the game largely iterated on what
had been seen before in the new super
mario brothers series
it came with a raft of new if minor
features on the power up front players
got
flying squirrel mario which while fun to
play as felt like nintendo was starting
to reach the limits of their imagination
then there were the baby yoshi's each of
which carried their own special
abilities
which you could carry through levels and
then the world map itself saw some
slight enhancements opting for one
larger map much like that scene in super
mario world
as i mentioned before new super mario
bros u was not as big a success as its
small screen counterpart
largely due to the lackluster
performance of the wii u but nintendo
came back swinging with one of the wii
u's greatest games
just a year later
2013 saw the release of super mario 3d
world
and this one was all about cats which
instantly made it the game of the year
ain't that right super mario 3d world
expanded on its small screen predecessor
and then
some asides from the introduction of cat
mario which was the greatest power up in
all mario don't at me
3d world made use of pretty much every
bell and whistle on the wii u
had a plethora of new power-ups and even
included four-player multiplayer for the
first time in a 3d mario game
the multiplayer in particular was a high
point for the sequel with each of the
characters having their own unique
abilities
that made each play session uniquely
frenetic from a gameplay standpoint 3d
world played in a similar manner to 3d
land
levels were structured like a
traditional 2d mario but you had the
freedom to roam
anywhere and even climb walls if you
were cat mario which by the way was the
best power up if i hadn't already
mentioned
there was a massive 117 courses in total
with each world drip feeding new
mechanics and power-ups across
ever-evolving courses and 3d world even
gave us the isometric platforming of
captain toad
before nintendo spun those levels off
into a completely separate game
sadly 3d world remains one of the least
played mario titles
thanks largely to it debuting on the wii
u it sold so poorly in fact that here in
the uk it debuted in the charts at
number 14
just behind a little game called knack
the british public sure did mario dirty
with that one i can only apologize
after 30 years of making mario games
nintendo finally packed it in
and just asked players to make their own
levels super mario maker was a meaty
mario level editor that launched for the
wii u in 2015
and basically played out as a greatest
hits reel for 2d mario
mario maker basically handed the keys to
the mushroom kingdom
over to players and let them create and
publish their own levels across
four unique styles super mario bros
super mario bros 3
super mario world and new super mario
brothers it allowed you to create a
whole slate of deviously difficult
levels
as long as you could finish your own mad
creation that is and offered a huge
wealth of options with which to do so
super mario maker was the perfect 30th
birthday present to the fans
and they responded in kind by creating
over 7 million courses
[Music]
by 2016 mario had been on his fair share
of handhelds but he'd never been on a
smartphone
super mario run was a revolution of
sorts in its own little way
but not really for the game itself it
was a small revolution because it was
the first official mario title developed
for a non-nintendo console
when it came to the gameplay mario run
didn't really evolve the formula
in fact it pretty much devolved it back
to its basics taking inspiration from
classic autorunners like cannabolt
and jetpack joyride mario run saw the
controls paired right back to just a
simple touch of the screen
if you touch the screen mario jumped if
you held the screen for longer he'd jump
for longer
and well that was largely it shigiro
miyamoto said it was even designed that
way so you could play with one hand and
eat a
hamburger with the other which is just
the most wholesome miyamoto thing
ever
[Music]
with the wii u confined to the trash can
of history r.i.p
nintendo moved forward with arguably
their greatest console
to date and also arguably their greatest
mario game to date too
super mario odyssey felt like a full-on
celebration of
every aspect of the franchise that had
come so far
[Music]
employing a sandbox structure to its
gameplay odyssey crafted a gameplay
experience that was equal parts new and
refreshing
and quintessentially mario and at the
center of it all was the capture
mechanic
mario odyssey introduced cappy into the
franchise a cute little character that
took up residence in mario's hat
and gave players the ability to capture
a whole range of enemies characters and
items with spectacular results
you could capture over 100 different
things across odyssey
a large portion of them classic mario
enemies from across the series and in
one slightly creepy instance a human in
new donk city
courses and worlds were a thing of the
past as mario odyssey introduced
kingdoms into the franchise
expansive open world sandboxes that were
littered with power moons for players to
hunt for
unlike previous 3d mario games you
weren't kicked back to a central hub
world after you collected a moon which
allowed you to uncover secrets at your
own pace
these varied sandbox arenas were full of
life and color too
whether it was the steampunk gardens of
the wooded kingdom the pop art
aesthetics of the luncheon kingdom
or the desert vistas of the sand kingdom
super mario odyssey was a huge success
for nintendo
becoming the fastest selling mario game
since new super mario bros wii
almost a decade before this was no doubt
powered by the success of the switch
but odyssey was also a huge success
critically with many saying it felt like
the spiritual successor to super mario
64
and us here at gamespot slapping another
10 out of 10 on a mario game
only the second in the franchise after
super mario galaxy 2.
most recent main series release into the
mario franchise was the follow-up to
2015 super mario maker
which basically just expanded on the
brilliance of the original asides from a
raft of new items enemies and power-ups
there were three major developments in
mario maker 2.
the first was a brand new core style
that was based on the super mario 3d
world aesthetic
and offered unique gameplay mechanics
within its level design secondly after
numerous requests from fans
nintendo gave players the opportunity to
create their very own world maps too
and lastly and perhaps most
substantially mario maker 2 included a
story campaign which offered up over 100
nintendo created courses for players to
tear through
mario maker 2 was an even bigger success
than its predecessor largely thanks to
the larger player base on the switch
selling over 5 million copies to date
the super mario franchise has come a
long way since it started life as a
potential popeye license game thank god
that never happened
from its 2d roots through to its
groundbreaking arrival in 3d
and then back again mario has been one
of the backbones of gaming since he
first debuted in the 80s
and he's hoping he keeps innovating for
many long years to come
and that is the evolution of the super
mario franchise 35 years of memory
summed up in 30 minutes
i've really enjoyed going back through
this amazing franchise for its 35th
birthday and i really hope you enjoyed
watching this video too
let me know your favorite mario game in
the comment section below
and i'll see you next time